The jogan Experience here's what's crazy
man I've been freaking out over the last
like few weeks like at night time like
at night time I'll be alone and I just
start thinking about the future of the
world and I start like legit freaking
out like what what would happen if we
were like legit Armageddon Mad Max
nuclear war like how far are we away
from that and it just it's it could just
give me anxiety before I go to sleep I'd
just be laying there going [__] like how
does this all resolve and then this
[__] Israel thing pops off and now
I'm like legit freaked out I've been uh
definitely buying a lot of stuff lately
for my house like into the world [__]
like I'm getting Tesla solar right now
you know battery packs so I can live off
the grid and yeah that's a good move
yeah yeah if you can get your house
solar that's a big move just [__] I
me you know at a certain point in time
what is it what's the electricity even
getting you other than keeping the
lights on though what what I'm scared of
is like all communic are gone like how
how hard would it be to shut down our
power grid how hard would it be to blow
a few satellites up and no one knows
[__] yeah that's why like that that that
starlink the you know the satellites
thing I'm thinking about getting that
even though I have I have great internet
but you know just because oh what if
it's yeah it's scary yeah I was in the
mountains in Utah and they had starlink
and it was great it works everywhere
it's really but people keep thinking
it's UFOs oh yeah like people keep
filming it fly what is that yeah that
dots in the air like I was telling you
the other day I'm sitting at home like
wondering about the fate of the world
are we are we literally going to be in a
[__] mad because you don't think
anything's going to go bad until it goes
bad you know you remember the day before
9/11 it was just [__] normal America
yeah yeah and then the next day chaos
and then everyone's riding around with
an American flag on their car like
anything can happen and if anything does
happen like how how ready what how much
is the world going to change I mean like
if you think about any sort of like
horrific natural disaster that has hit
Humanity since the beginning of time
whether it's super volcanoes or
earthquakes or any of these chaotic
things when those things happen when
when the Mongols roll into your town
when you know when na Nazi Germany
starts taking over Europe like [__] we
want to think that that can't happen but
100% that can happen and when I when I
[__] when I'm alone at night and I'm
a little
high that's the thing that freaks me out
the most the things that freaks me out
the most is international conflicts
between superpowers and how they're
willing to kill a certain amount of
people right so like how what's a What's
the number where they won't cross that
line because if you've got groups of
people that are willing to shoot
missiles into apartment buildings and
and and and fly Jets down and gun people
down and you've seen all those crazy
drone if we're willing to kill a certain
amount of people like what's the line
where they won't cross what's the line
is it a million people is it a nuclear
bomb you know what what is the line
there's probably no line and when you
think about how much people loved
America after 911 the whole world was
like on America's side and how much we
[__] that up in 23 years or 22 years
yeah [__] that up [__] that up a a
million innocent people die because the
Iraq War
F that everybody knows that too we need
a 912
immediately we probably are doe for one
that's what's scary when you see this
Israel thing like it scares the [__] out
of me yeah it scares the [__] out of me
because when I see something like that
happen you know there's like there's no
clear way this resolves peacefully like
this is bad this is real bad and and
Israel's going to go into Palestine and
they're already bombing and it's all
and is there a retaliation for that and
what happens then and who what other
countries get involved and
[__] [__] man it just really puts into
perspective that there's some [__] going
on that you're not thinking about
because it's not in your life so if
you're a guy like you or I let's say us
because we're comedians so we're hanging
out the comedy club we're doing podcasts
that's our world our world is [__]
around with people our our world is
telling jokes our world is hanging out
with our friends and doing shows their
world is killing people their world is
controlling resources and it's not they
don't play fair like they they release
stories that aren't true they use
disinformation to switch narratives they
have social media posts that aren't real
so they can get people riled up about
certain
things and then they're also
coordinating milit Ary attacks that's
their world we just don't think about
that world because we're not in that
world but people have been in that world
since the beginning of time what they've
done with us is they've sheltered Us in
such a way and then censored all the
mainstream media in such a way that they
completely control The Narrative of how
you think about what can and cannot
happen in the world and why these things
are
happening and we're seeing that right
now we're seeing that like in your face
where you're like what and you're also
seeing people with massive amounts of
conspiracies now right and whenever
something like that happens there's
always the people that are like how did
they not know this was going to happen
like isn't this the most sophisticated
surveillance systems in the world this
like Israel is the they're the people
that invented Pegasus that's that [__]
that gets on your phone where they can
listen to anybody and they have like
they they have that Iron Dome that
protects them against missiles did you
ever see that working M they were just
showing it the other night it's show
videos of the Iron Dome working it's
crazy so as Hamas is launching these
missiles they're shooting missiles at
the missiles and blowing them up in the
sky it's wild look at this oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's old school Missile
Command remember that video again yeah I
mean you have to be 100% accurate
because any one of these is going to
kill a bunch of
people but I mean just imagine living in
Israel and you go outside and you're
seeing missiles getting hit by bombs
look at this it's insane look at this
they're just jacking him in the sky but
if they miss one that's a wrap I mean
how much do how much do each one of
these missiles that they're shooting at
these other missiles cost right that's
what I was think is million dollars
million dollars million do and how are
they getting all the money to shoot
those missiles at Israel like all of it
is crazy yeah and someone tweeted see if
this is true that this happened right
after uh Biden the Biden Administration
released a bunch of funds to Iran I
think it was like $6 billion really and
then these people in Hamas are thanking
Iran for funding this WOW but it's you
what's real yeah what's real that sounds
like how much is how much of this is
real yeah have you heard this Air Force
successfully tested secret new stealth
missile with mock
nuke a stealth stealth missile with a
mock nuke okay
B52 nuclear weapons are aging and the
Pentagon plans to spend more than 600
billion to keep the potentially
world-ending weapons in fighting shape
what a great idea at in this article I
saw it said that they were being
controlled by floppy discs up until 2019
well those are accurate that's top of
the food chain they're updating Tech but
okay floppy discs in 2019 but some of
the old Tech is still solid the lrso and
mock nuke ref fired from a B52 a sturdy
and reliable bomber first manufactured
in the ' 50s to missiles arm are in fact
designed to work with this decades old
bomber H but a mo a stealth nuke is
crazy yeah that's crazy all of it's
crazy the fact that that's on the table
all of it's crazy and also the fact that
we haven't nked anybody since 1945
nobody's nuked anybody that's good it's
promising right it's promising we got it
celebrate 100 years but it it's hard to
imagine that it's going to last like
that forever
seems like someone's going to get crazy
that's the question it's like if you're
willing to kill answer to your question
each missile is 40,000 to $50,000
according to a researcher at Israel's
Institute for National Security
studies
wow wow 20 of them is a million bucks so
yeah so the question is where's where's
this we where are these weapons coming
from and and then there was also
questions of whether or not uh weapons
that we left in Afghanistan were being
used m which is that is crazy Trump was
hilarious doing this this uh
conversation about that where he was
telling them like why don't we you know
get the weapons out of there why don't
we fill them up with gas and drive them
over to Pakistan and he's like he said
that find the video is Millie because
he's hilarious Trump trump literally
acts like a comedian he is kind of has
been the first thing
yes oh okay the bid administra
Administration informed Congress on
Monday that it has taken concrete steps
to carry out a prisoner exchange with
Iran issuing a waiver that will give
Tran access to 6 billion in Iranian oil
Revenue that had been blocked by us
sanctions according to a state
department document sent to Congress and
that was a month ago that was a month
ago yeah on September 11th and then you
all these stories the last day I'd
say
yeah so they they gave him a lot of
funds yeah and then this happened
he needs to do a charge back it's just
we are yeah call
PayPal tell me got
defrauded we're in the middle of a game
that we don't we we're not aware of just
like we were talking about before like
that's the game they play the game
they're playing is war and money I mean
just the amount of money that's been
spent in Ukraine and like what kind of
accounting are you guys doing you guys
doing good accounting over there like
does everybody know where every [__]
dollar went or is it just like let's go
crazy yeah yeah exactly yeah you're
talking about so much money like you
could Shuffle it over here and pull it
over why don't you look at Jesus how how
do you just leave weapons too I mean
don't they don't we know where all the I
mean if we have air tags on on on book
bag shouldn't they have like little air
tags on them dude that hold pull out was
an unmitigated disaster yeah nobody
thinks it was good nobody thinks it was
good nobody thinks it should have been
done that way I mean Trump was trying to
pull out a long time
ago and they were they were trying to
figure out like how many troops you have
to leave order to maintain the base and
and and get everybody out safe it is
It's tricky because when they know
you're pulling out but the fact they
left tanks and helicopters and [__] like
shut the [__] up yeah that's ridiculous
it's almost
like like if you want to go full tin
foil hat if you want to ensure there's
going to be more
conflict you leave weapons with the
Enemy awesome
weapons if you want to ensure there is
going to be more military action that
these these guys are pissed you were
occupying their country for 20 years you
left behind how many billion dollars
were the tanks and [__] of course
they're going to use it and so you tell
the mil milary guys like we're pulling
out but here's the Long play Long play
is there's you know no chance they're
not going to do something with all that
stuff and so we'll probably have to go
back in and then this time we'll really
go back in and we'll get control of the
lithium like we can't go now like if we
go all in now like we got to get them to
do something really stupid so then the
we can justify like a complete takeover
of the country and annihilation of the
the people that are the problem the
people that we left tanks
behind the thing about Afghanistan
though is like it's
so it's so difficult to get through you
know to we think of it as like a country
but it's mountains it's like everything
is mountains it's incredible landscape
and there's Greek cities there there's
ancient Greek cities that were abandoned
there during the time of Alexander the
Great and no archaeologists are studying
them like it's it's amazing it's an
amazing place and it also has crazy
amounts of resources in terms of like I
think there's a like an insane amount of
lithium there there's all sorts of [__]
there that's like really
valuable but everybody tries to take
over and they all fail
miserably it's like one of the ways that
they stomped out the Soviet Union was
fund funding the MU Jadin which later
became you know Al-Qaeda or the Taliban
was it was it muin they become a Taliban
or al-
Qaeda either way like they F the
Russians tried to take over forever and
then they gave up like [__] this it's
like too much you can't win over there
it's like you can't even go anywhere
can't get through the mountains you
can't just drive you can't just drive
tanks through it's a [__] wild place
an almost unconquerable
place it would be cool to see in the
future if that does eventually become
somewhere you could go and enjoy the
used to be people used to go there's
like videos of people walking around the
streets of Cabell it used to be a place
where people would go and
vacation yeah force fields come on force
fields dude it's none of that's G to
help all goes back to force fields yes
if we come in and put a big force field
there I don't think so we leave our
force fields
behind yeah I feel safer living in
Austin though now that we're in the
middle of a country just in case of War
goes
crazy unless they decide to like Nuke
Dallas
yeah